ulcerative colitis is one of the most
common forms of inflammatory bowel
disease and is characterized by
inflammation of the colon and the rectum
the walls of the colon
also known as the mucosa become inflamed
and no longer provide an effective
barrier between the inner cavity and the
surrounding connective tissue allowing
gut microbes to cross the epithelial
layer this causes inflammation of the
mucosa and leads to a raft of unpleasant
symptoms such as abdominal pain diarrhea
fatigue and rectal bleeding
there are several commonly used
anti-inflammatory and immunosuppressive
drugs but they come with side effects
and aren't long-lasting for many
patients currently 15 percent of people
with ulcerative colitis will require
surgery to remove some or all of the
colon within 20 years of diagnosis
luckily new insights into the immunology
of this condition are helping scientists
develop new effective treatments one new
class of treatments is aimed at
preventing the information in the first
place by bolstering the physical
integrity of the colons epithelium this
keeps the immune triggering bugs
confined to the interior of the colon
some of these treatments work by
exploiting a human protein called il 22
which helps strengthen the epithelial
layer one new drug in development
targets the receptor for il 22 on the
epithelium itself activating it and
thereby initiating healing of epithelial
cells and the mucus layer this drug is
currently in Phase two trials
researchers are also trying to use a
plant product called indigo Naturalist
which encourages immune cells in the
area to release il 22 again healing the
epithelial barrier there are also new
therapies emerging that prevent immune
cells from entering the affected area
where they might become activated to
invoke an inflammatory response one way
to do this is to inhibit proteins called
integrins which live on the surface of T
cells a new antibody drug that works his
way stops T cells from getting across
the blood vessel wall into the mucosa
and also blocks their binding to the
epithelium this drug appears to
effectively reduce pain and inflammation
another group of drugs uses a totally
different approach targeting key
inflammatory signals between different
immune cells
for example one new drug tampers with
the cellular machinery inside t cells so
that they no longer respond to messages
from macrophages in a pivotal Phase
three trial this drug induced remission
in over 40 percent of patients and has
now been approved for the treatment of
active ulcerative colitis a final
approach to treating this disease is to
restore the healthy balance of the gut
microbiome one way of doing this is to
use probiotic bacteria streams adding
these commensal bacteria back into the
intestines gut community has been shown
to quell information and restore normal
intestinal function one particular
probiotic known as Ecoline mislay has
been shown to keep symptoms at bay just
as effectively as widely used
anti-inflammatory drugs fecal
transplantation from healthy donors is
also being experimented with although
results to date are conflicting at least
one recent study on multi-donor stool
transplantation has shown promising
results however eliminating symptoms in
a quarter of patients as new approaches
to tackling this disease come onto the
market the hope is that more patients
will be free of symptoms for longer and
won't go on to need aggressive surgery